بعد غروب الشمس تتناول هذه الاسره
السودانيه الفاتوره في لحظه صمت تنقطع فيه
اصوات المدافع ويرتفع صوت الاذان في
استراحه قصيره من الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
الضائقه الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها السودان
منذ سنوات يسعى المواطنون لتجاهلها ولو
مؤقتا على مائده الافطار حيث باتت واقعا
يؤرقهم لا يمكنهم توقع تبعاته في ظل
القتال المحتدمه
وبالرغم من انهم ربما تجاهلوا بشكل مؤقت
مشاكلهم الاقتصاديه الا نسمات الغذاء التي
تلوح في الافق اصبحت حقيقه واقعه في
السودان استمرار القتال تسبب في تفاقم
الوضع الانساني المتازم بالفعل 15 مليون
شخص بالكاد تتوفر لديهم مستلزمات الغذاء
الاساسيه بحسب تقرير للامم المتحده
تقارير اخرى تشير الى ان نحو اربعه ملايين
طفل دون الخامسه يعانون من بوادر سوء
التغذيه
المعارك الدائره حاليا الحقت اضرارا
مباشره في البنيه التحتيه عائلات بالكامل
استبدلت المشروبات الرمضانيه بالمياه
بعدما استهدفت محطات المياه في بعض
الاحياء مثل بحر شمالي الخرطوم
عائلات اخرى لجات الى الاكتفاء بوجبه
واحده فقط في اليوم في سبيل التعايش مع
الظروف الصعبه الاحياء الاوفر حظا يقتنص
سكانها فرصه هدوء الاشتباكات ليهرعوا الى
محلات البقاله ليجدوا ارففها فارغه تماما
خاصه التي تحتوي على المياه المعدنيه
بالنسبه لاغلاق الطعم لسوبر ماركت
والدكاكين
السيناريو الاكثر سوءا الذي لم يتوقعه
السودانيون كان اعلان برنامج الغذاء
العالمي وقف مساعداته للبلاد على وقع مقتل
ثلاثه من موظفيه نتيجه الاشتباكات بين
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات